for people who don't know because i
think a lot of people probably assumed
you were independent this whole time
because you moved around like an
independent artist
but you were on atlantic for how many
years forever
um but the thing is and this is the
thing with a lot of people because i had
somebody arguing recently like
um oh you were on a label so you can't
talk and it's like actually being
shelved on a label is worse than being
independent i promise you
no the label never did [ __ ] for you yeah
so i'm like being shelved on a label is
actually way worse than doing it on your
own because
i couldn't drop music you know what i
mean like i couldn't upload to
like something like dsps yeah it's ten
dollars to upload on tunecore i couldn't
even do that so now i'm dealing with
i could be in breach of contract i could
do it like all these
different things going on and i'm
uploading to youtube because it's safe
but you know but then so i'm being seen
as an artist but
not really being able to drop music so
you can not move
you really can't monetize what you would
like it was bad bro i didn't have there
was times when i was broke as [ __ ]
and like literally i just i
i let the world not know that because i
was just like yo that'll be the end of
my career if i literally let people know
how bad i'm [ __ ] doing but
at the same time i had my my you know my
marriage or whatever to pay bills or
whatever
i never had i wasn't i never did no
questionable [ __ ]
because like i'm a hard worker i'll
[ __ ] work at the grocery store if i
need to like i don't give a [ __ ] you
know
um so to me i
moved how i needed a move and i gave
atlantic their
their due respect for giving me an
opportunity like i've said before i
don't
i don't say that they [ __ ] ruined my
life or anything i think part of it was
like i should have known when to leave i
i shouldn't have given it
the the time i did you know like same
thing with friends sometimes like or a
relationship like
you knew when it was time to go and you
stuck around with the hopes of [ __ ]
getting better you know or like
you were like damn like you know one
time i remember i was gonna when i wrote
this song called i don't want to leave
i was crying when i wrote that i
literally was like about to leave
atlantic and i literally named the song
i don't want to leave because i was like
i signed to this thinking that i was
going to represent for my culture and
for my family and i was going to be put
on this
platform where i could [ __ ] yeah no
not even a pedestal for me a platform
for me to be able to speak on something
that hasn't been on a large scale